foreign
people are funny we're constantly trying
to understand and interpret the world
around us
I live in a house with two black cats
and let me tell you every time I see a
black bunched up sweater out of the
corner of my eye I think it's a cat it's
not just the things we see sometimes we
attribute more intelligence that might
actually be there
maybe you've seen the dogs on Tick Tock
they have these little buttons that say
things like walk or treat
they're they can push them to
communicate some things with their
owners and their owners think they use
them to communicate some pretty
impressive things
but do the dogs know what they're saying
or perhaps you've heard the story of
clever Hans the horse and he could do
math and not just like simple math
problems really complicated ones like if
the eighth day of the month falls on a
Tuesday what's the date of the following
Friday
it's like pretty impressive for a horse
unfortunately Hans wasn't doing math but
what he was doing was equally impressive
Hans had learned to watch the people in
the room to tell when he should stop
tapping his hoof so he communicated his
Answers by tapping his hoof
it turns out that if you know the answer
to if the eighth day of the month falls
on a Tuesday what's the date of the
following Friday you will subconsciously
change your posture once the horse is
given the correct 18 taps
so Hans couldn't do math but he had
learned to watch people in the room who
could do math which I mean still pretty
impressive for a horse
but this is an old picture and we would
not fall for clever Hans today or would
we
well I work in Ai and let me tell you
things are wild there have been multiple
examples of people being completely
convinced that AI understands them
in
2022 a Google engineer thought that
Google's AI was sentient
and you may have had a really human-like
conversation with something like chat
GPT
but models we're training today are so
much better than the models we had even
five years ago it really is remarkable
so at this super crazy moment in time
let's ask the super crazy question
does AI understand us or are we having
our own clever Hans moment
some philosophers think that computers
will never understand language to
illustrate this they develop something
they call the Chinese room argument
in the Chinese room there is a person
hypothetical person who does not
understand Chinese but he has along with
him a set of instructions that tell him
how to respond in Chinese to any Chinese
sentence
here's how the Chinese room Works a
piece of paper comes in through a slot
in the door has something written on
Chinese in Chinese on it the person uses
their instructions to figure out how to
respond they write the response down on
a piece of paper and then send it back
out through the door
to somebody who speaks Chinese standing
outside this room it might seem like the
person inside the room speaks Chinese
but we know they do not
because no knowledge of Chinese is
required to follow the instructions
performance on this task does not show
that you know Chinese
so what does that tell us about AI well
when you and I stand outside of the room
when we speak to one of these Chinese
sorry one of these AIS like chat GPT we
are the person standing outside the room
we are feeding in English sentences
we're getting English sentences back
it really looks like the models
understand us it really looks like they
know English
but under the hood these models are just
following a set of instructions albeit
complex
how do we know if AI understands us
to answer that question let's go back to
the Chinese room again let's say we have
two Chinese rooms in one Chinese room is
somebody who actually speaks Chinese
and in the other room is our imposter
when the person who actually speaks
Chinese gets a piece of paper that says
something in Chinese in it they can read
it no problem
but when our imposter gets again he has
to use his set of instructions to figure
out how to respond
from the outside it might be impossible
to distinguish these two rooms but we
know inside something really different
is happening
to illustrate that let's say Inside the
Minds of our two people inside of our
two rooms is a little scratch pad and
everything they have to remember in
order to do this task has to be written
on that little scratch pad
if we could see what was written on that
scratch Pad we would be able to tell how
different their approach to the task is
so though the input and the output of
these two rooms might be exactly the
same the process of getting from input
to Output completely different
so again what does that tell us about AI
again if AI even if it generates
completely plausible dialogue answers
questions just like we would expect it
may still be an imposter of sorts if we
want to know if AI understands language
like we do we need to know what it's
doing we need to get inside to see what
it's doing is it an imposter or not we
need to see its scratch pad and we need
to be able to compare it to the scratch
Pad of somebody who actually understands
language
but like scratch pads in brains that's
not something we can actually see right
well it turns out that we can kind of
see scratch pads in brains using
something like fmri or EEG we can take
what are like little snapshots of the
brain while it's reading so have people
read words or stories and then take
pictures of their brain and those brain
images are like fuzzy autofocus pictures
of the scratch Pad of the brain they
tell us a little bit about how the brain
is processing and representing
information while you read
so here are three brain images taken
while a person read the word apartment
house and celery
you can see just with your naked eye
that the brain image for apartment and
house are more similar to each other
than they are to the brain image for
celery
and you know of course that apartments
and houses are more similar than they
are to celery just the words
so I said another way
the brain uses its scratch Pad when
reading the words apartment and house in
a way that's more similar than when you
read the word celery
the scratch Pad tells us a little bit
about how the brain represents the
language it's not a perfect picture of
what the brain's doing but it's good
enough
okay so we have scratch pads for the
brain now we need a scratch pad for AI
so inside a lot of AIS is a neural
network and inside of a neural network
is a bunch of these little neurons so
here the neurons are like these little
gray circles and we would like to know
what is the scratch Pad of a neural
network well when we feed in a word into
a neural network
each of the little neurons computes a
number
those little numbers I'm representing
here with colors so every neuron
computes its little number and those
numbers tell us something about how the
neural network is processing language
taking together all of those little
circles paint us a picture of how the
neural network is representing language
and they give us the scratch Pad of the
neural network
okay great now we have two scratch pads
one from the brain and one from Ai and
we want to know is AI doing something
like what the brain is doing
how can we test that
here's what researchers have come up
with we're going to train a new model
that new model is going to look at
neural network scratch pad for a
particular word and try to predict the
brain scratch pad for the same word we
can do it the other way around too so
let's train a new model it's going to
look at the neural network scratch pad
for a particular word and try to predict
the brain scratch pad
if the brain and AI are doing nothing
alike have nothing in common we won't be
able to do this prediction task it won't
be possible to predict one from the
other
so we've reached a fork in the road and
you can probably tell I'm about to tell
you one of two things
I'm going to tell you AI is amazing or
I'm going to tell you AI is an imposter
researchers like me love to remind you
that AI is nothing like the brain and
that is true
but could it also be the AI in the brain
share something uncommon
so we've done the scratch Pad prediction
task and it turns out 75 percent of the
time the predicted neural network
scratch pad for a particular word is
more similar to the true neural network
scratch pad for that word than it is to
the neural network scratch pad for some
other randomly chosen word 75 is much
better than chance
what about for more complicated things
not just words but sentences even
stories again this scratch Pad
prediction task Works we're able to
predict the neural network scratch pad
from the brain and vice versa
amazing
so does that mean that neural networks
and AI understand language just like we
do
well truthfully no
the scratch Pad prediction tasks show
above chance accuracy
the underlying correlations are still
pretty weak and the neural networks are
inspired by the brain they don't have
the same same kind of structure and
complexity that we see in the brain
Now lyrics also don't exist in the world
a neural network has never opened a door
or seen a sunset heard a baby cry
can a neural network that doesn't
actually exist in the world hasn't
really experienced the world really
understand language about the world
still these scratch Pad prediction
experiments have held up multiple brain
Imaging experiments multiple neural
networks we've also found that as the
neural networks get more accurate we
also they also start to use their
scratch pad in a way that becomes more
brain-like and it's not just language
we've seen similar results in navigation
and vision
so AI is not doing exactly what the
brain is doing but it's not completely
random either
so from where I sit if we want to know
if AI really understands language like
we do we need to get inside of the
Chinese room we need to know what the AI
is doing and we need to be able to
compare that to what people are doing
when they understand language
AI is moving so fast
today I'm asking you does AI understand
language that might seem like a silly
question in 10 years or 10 months
but one thing will remain true we are
meaning making humans and we are going
to continue to look for meaning and
interpret the world around us and we
will need to remember
that if we only look at the input and
output of AI it's very easy to be fooled
we need to get inside of the
metaphorical room of AI
in order to see what's happening
it's what's inside that counts
thank you
[Applause]